in 2017 apple shocked the world by
raising the price of their flagship
iphone model to
999
and it's been at that same price for the
past few years until now yes it's
looking like apple is about to raise the
price on their iphone 14 pro and 14 pro
max models coming next month but don't
worry it sounds like bad news but there
is a silver lining that i'm going to
reveal and discuss in this video and i'm
also going to talk about why they're
raising the price and what features we
should be expecting as well getting
right into it while a lot of people were
expecting apple to raise the prices of
these models ming chuquo the reliable
and famous apple leaker finally came out
and confirmed that apple is going to be
raising the prices of their iphone 14
pro model so yes just the pro models not
the regular ones and he did say
specifically that they're gonna raise
the iphone 14 series average sale price
by about 15 now that does not mean that
they're going to raise the iphone 14 pro
price by 15
to 11 50
that's not what it means it just means
that on average that's going to be the
average sale price now this leak does
confirm a previous leak from a korean
blogger who said that the iphone 14
regular model will stay the same price
as the iphone 13 and that means that the
iphone mini is going away no more mini
for the 14. so in terms of my own
thoughts and predictions for the pricing
this is actually from december the 6.1
inch iphone 14 will be 7.99 then you pay
a hundred dollars more for the larger
max or plus model then you have 1099
for the 14 pro which is a hundred dollar
increase and then 11.99 for the pro max
also a hundred dollars more than the
smaller size and it's really cool
because both larger models will have
identical specs just a larger display
and battery and i know what you're
thinking apple is crazy they're greedy
they want all your money by increasing
these prices but there is a silver
lining like i said in the intro and that
is the chance that we might actually get
the 14 pro model with an increased
256 gigs of storage compared to the
current 128 and that would actually
not be that big of a price increase of
course you wouldn't be able to get the
lower end model you'll have to go
straight up to 256 but of course this is
gonna add a lot of value to the 14 pro
if it comes with 256 gigs of storage
however i did speak to mark german and
he has some doubts about this he thinks
it's going to stay at 128 gigs so i'm
not exactly sure but there are some
really good hints and reasons for why it
could jump up to 256.
first of all we did get a rumor last
year that the iphone 14 could feature up
to two terabytes of storage compared to
the current one terabyte iphone 13 pro
so it would actually make sense for the
entry level to start at 256 because it's
like a bigger range and that could make
sense why they're going up to two
terabytes and as for another reason with
the iphone 13 lineup apple finally
raised the base storage of the regular
models to
128 gigs which is exactly the base
storage of the current 13 pro so maybe
it's time for apple to up the base
storage of the pro models to 256 so
there's actually some differentiation
between the two
and that could actually make you want to
pay more for the pro model because you
see it has double the storage and that's
a nice incentive to upgrade even though
it starts at 1100
and getting even more interesting if you
look at the current iphone 13 pro the
price of the 256 gig storage model is
actually 10.99 which is the price i
think the iphone 14 pro is gonna start
at so
if that model does get 256 this would
essentially not be a price hike at all
apple would just be cutting the lower
end 128 gig model completely forcing you
to go up to 256 gigs of storage and in
that way they're going to be raising
their average sales price and their
revenue which is of course good for them
and it helps them eat the cost of a lot
of the features that are coming to the
iphone 14 pro which i'm about to get to
in this video now one of the main
reasons for apple to start the 14 pro
off with 256 gigs of storage is this
leak from last year saying that the 2022
iphone pro model would feature a 48
megapixel camera that supports 8k
video yes 8k video and he did come back
recently in march and confirmed that yes
the 14 pro and pro max are getting
upgrades to the wide camera to 48 mega
pixels which is why the camera bump is
gonna be bigger and here in my tweet
from june 10th after wwdc i talked about
the m2 chip and how it now supports 8k
encoding and decoding in h.264 hevc and
prores and how that is exactly what
apple is likely to use on the iphone 14
pro in order to encode the actual 8k
video and also decode it when playing
back so there's not a huge load on the
chip itself but on the media engine and
that's how apple is going to pull off
crazy good 8k video recording at up to
60 fps in my opinion now of course if
you're shooting 8k or even 8k 60fps
you're going to use a lot of storage and
maybe that is why apple might make the
base model start with 256 gigs and i
know a lot of you guys are going to
complain because lightning is sticking
around this year and we're not getting
usbc until the iphone 15 lineup but i do
believe that this year's iphone 14 pro
is also gonna feature a faster usb 3.0
lightning connector to make faster
transfers of those higher end 8k video
clips and this is also a big reason why
a lot of people are gonna want the
iphone 14 pro because it has the faster
lightning connector compared to the
regular 14 models that'll likely stick
to the slower lightning of course
because they're not going to have the 8k
video recording now we did get more and
more reports from different sources that
were confirming that yes the 48
megapixel camera is coming to the 14 pro
now the interesting point i want to make
about the iphone 14 pro potentially
getting 256 gigs of storage is the fact
that the current iphone 13 pro requires
256 gigs of storage to shoot 4k pro res
video yes apple actually has that
limitation and it's literally one of the
main reasons why i bought the 256 gig
for the first time even though i ended
up not even shooting the prores which is
dumb but the 256 gig is useful so maybe
that's why apple is likely to go up to
that new base storage now alongside that
i've got a bunch of other leaks and
rumors that i'm going through that talk
about why it's going to be so worth it
for the iphone 14 pro compared to the
regular iphone 14 lineup despite the
higher new price first of all the only
the pro models in the iphone 14 lineup
are going to be getting the new a16 ship
while the lower end models will be
sticking to the same a15 now on top of
that the pro models are going to be
featuring slightly larger screen sizes
just a little bit bigger than they are
before and that is of course because of
the new pill plus hole design replacing
the notch and the narrow bezels for
example you can see right here that the
bezels are going to be 20
thinner
than they are on the iphone 13 pro max
which is a massive
massive difference and you can actually
see this right here you can see the full
iphone 14 lineup you got the promax the
regular max the pro and the regular and
if you look closely the bezels are for
sure thinner on the pro models and of
course you see that nice design where
they finally get rid of that notch and
not only that they have a super thin
speaker enclosure right here looks very
nice compared to the notch that's going
to be sticking around on the regular
iphone 14 models and that's of course
why so many people are going to be
trying to go for that 14 pro model at
least in my opinion and they'll be
willing to pay the extra price of course
you can see ice universes leak right
here showing off this new display glass
panel right here man those bezels are
thin i think this is going to look
absolutely wonderful now on top of that
the 14 pro model will be getting a
better oled screen than the iphone 14 so
it's going to be a better grade in terms
of the actual material but it's also
going to have better technology as well
because it apparently is going to
support and always on display
finally like android has had this for
years but this will support an always-on
display because the refresh rate of the
display panel will go down to one hertz
finally and this is what apple is going
to use for the always-on display to save
that battery life and we even got some
more evidence in the recent ios 16 beta
suggesting that it is coming and even in
xcode 14 beta showing that we could be
getting that always on display honestly
i think at this point i'm 100 sure that
we're getting an always-on display and
that's going to be exclusive to the pro
models not the regular iphone 14 of
course it's also going to have the pro
motion 120 hertz so i mean there's going
to be some massive differences this year
between the 14 and the 14 pro now not
only that but it looks like apple is
going to be aggressively testing
vapor chamber cooling systems for the
2022 iphones and i think this will also
be exclusive to the pro models as well
because they'll have the higher end a16
chip and they're gonna be more pro for
more performance so it'll be worth it to
put in the new vapor chamber systems
into that not only that but the 14 pro
is gonna have six gigs of faster ram
this year which is lp ddr5 compared to
the 14 and the 14 max which are still
using the 4x so that's another
difference and of course you can see
right here
because of the new camera systems that
are insane on the pro models the camera
bumps are gonna look huge
and they're not just doing it to make
them big they're doing it because they
have to because if they're making those
cameras that much better especially with
a 48 megapixel sensor and 8k video
capable they have to make the lenses
themselves longer because you have to do
that to make the optics and everything
work properly and that of course is
evidenced by this rumor that the main
sensor on the 14 pro is going to be 21
wider for the 48 megapixel images and 8k
video so going back to the main topic of
this video the price increase for the 14
pro honestly is justified with
everything that apple is throwing at us
in terms of feature upgrades and
differences compared to the regular
iphone 14 models especially if they give
us 256 gigs of base storage on the 14
pro i mean this is going to be a killer
deal especially since they're getting
rid of the notch finally giving us the
biggest camera upgrade ever 8k video
i think that that price increase is
going to be well worth it and if you can
afford it you should probably go with
that model because i think it's just
going to be incredible so if you
disagree with me let me know in the
comment section below but if you enjoyed
this video click the circle above to
subscribe and definitely check out one
of those two right over there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]
you